the Kyrie thing it's so heavy tech but
the Kyrie things interesting did you
hear about the cutter yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah cries Kyrie doesn't wanna
play basketball
this is Kyrie trying to be woke to [ __ ]
more white girls I know this guy I see
through his hustle I see through you
Kyrie you don't think it's real you
don't think it's legit what a stupid
[ __ ] argument go go go go make yo we
can't effect social change if we play
you know who wants to play LeBron James
you know he's done a lot more for social
change than you LeBron James great
argument is always on the front line
speaking whenever he got to speak Kyrie
talking about [ __ ] three eyes the
whole past year not playing complaining
about not being the [ __ ] Alpha like
he wants to be where are you on social
issues this whole time great for now
your solution is to stay silent and do
nothing and that's how you affect social
change
great point I think that's a great point
I actually feel ain't it funny how we
switch on the Chappelle position in this
position yeah you're like Chappelle he's
gonna look the streets talk and I'm like
yeah and then I'm like Kyrie is gonna
live the streets talk and you're like
yeah I think we actually both agree
which is like like my issue is it
Chappell's like yo imma let the street
talk and then he put out this match
where he's talking but uh and I'm sure
you probably feel all that similar way
with Kyrie right is put uh so here's my
thinking about it as much as I want
[ __ ] basketball dunk as much as I
want a sport right we're in a very
unique time in history where there can
be a singular focus about one cause the
entire world is concerned about black
lives right and regardless if you want
to accept this or not a major part of it
is there's not a lot else going on I
know that sounds like a [ __ ] up thing
does that sound [ __ ] up yeah that's a
valid point there's not a lot coming on
so when there's not a lot going on you
can focus on something when you don't it
listen there are so many people I know
so many white people were like listen I
don't want anything bad to happen a
black guy I want them have equality yo
there's a March I gotta take my kids to
soccer practice man I want to be there
but I got taken
my wife I promise there's so many other
things did you were to do please all
have lives dog we all have [ __ ] lives
and right now there's nothing else to do
the one activity you're allowed to do
even a [ __ ] CDC is [ __ ] as they
are we're like you know you can do this
you can go outside you can marching a
protest
there's a singular focus on this issue
the second other things start opening
right you know to your point
Tiger King was enough to distract us
from racism Tiger King the second these
other things start opening your gonna
give us a thing to be distracted about
especially you're gonna open almost
right into the playoffs yeah so now are
we gonna watch LeBron play the [ __ ]
Celtics in the finals or are we gonna go
to this protest what we will do so do I
think Tyrese actions have for the most
of his career publicly been selfish just
publicly I can't say we does with his
private life publicly if they've been
selfish yes yes so it's really hard to
hear this from Kyrie and not assumed
selfishness which i think is what you
know I think it's a hundred percent so
anyway I'll give Chapelle
you got lis away with me you are in
credibility Carrie Hitler has it right
but I
the thing that flipped me was not Kyrie
it was Lou Williams okay
and I believe Lou cuz that's a real
[ __ ] the guy there's a story
that in Philly somebody was gonna
carjack Lou Williams and then recognize
it was Lou and ludus did so much in the
community he was like now me you're good
and you know he did he said I'm I'm
gonna take you guys some McDonald's bro
cuz the guy just wanted food to eat
incredible so it's like Lou was like we
have the ability to focus on this right
now let's do it now the NBA said I think
they're gonna give five hundred million
dollars if they start the season to the
cause yeah right now I actually think
what is more valuable than money is
attention yeah
so I really believe and I've told this
to my friends in the [ __ ] league and
I'm like you know honestly the best
thing for you all to do is cancel this
season and put all the focus on this but
before you cancel it make sure there are
specific demands that you want met I
think if they ask for a specific
thing I don't care what the [ __ ] it is
it you can chokehold body cameras it
could be reallocate the police but a
specific thing who owns these teams
Aakash billionaires when billionaires
get affected by things shits are such a
that's true we talked about this last
week economics and sanction is the only
peaceful way to make any change because
that economic sanction is violence yeah
we were talking about this we're gonna
do is on a peace in a society that
values money over human life and keep in
mind George Floyd was killed over a fake
$20 bill so that's the money they were
willing to kill his [ __ ] over a
fake $20 bill it society values money
over human life people do not understand
acts of violence towards humans as much
as they understand acts of violence
towards the money
yeah that's why rioting was effective
cuz it coming for the money and when you
cancel the season you come for the
billionaire's pockets the most powerful
influential people you get that [ __ ] all
sudden they get wind of that and they're
gonna go i'ma lose how many hundred
million dollars is it what nah I'm
calling up my governor I'm calling up my
senator I'm calling up the police chief
you activate those [ __ ] you
will get some real change and the only
way you do that is you come for their
[ __ ] pockets and the only way you do
that is you cancel the season or you say
we're not starting the season until we
get this specific demand met and don't
have to be the end-all be-all it has to
be something it's use your leverage
while you got it in good point that's
the that's what I'll say is very rare I
agree with Kyrie on anything that's a
good point
now you got me flip me make sense out
yeah and I agree with you 100% mark I
honey hole they hold out but they can't
it's been decided already right so
that's the thing that's the thing about
LeBron
I don't think LeBron wants to hold out
and Barry wants his legacy he wants his
room he wants his ring getting old he's
got a good shot this year and this is an
interesting time where it's like LeBron
has done so many amazing things this is
where someone like what's the fat black
dude this a sellout was the name
Whitlock Whitlock this is where you
criticize LeBron not when he's [ __ ]
open in schools now
doing this amazing stuff for the
community you criticize him where it's
like we didn't hear you talk about
anything with China because you didn't
want to [ __ ] up the bag which is
reasonable because you can do so much
with the bag you've been so generous
with your bank and now there's a
situation where there is an argument to
be made that the best thing to do is use
your political leverage right now with
the NBA with these billionaires to
actually make change and not start the
league so they can pad their pockets
with what little time they got left
that's where some might say yo that's
where your voice should go if LeBron sat
out the playoffs that would put him in
another national on of pathway dude that
puts him in the Muhammad Ali's Ali yeah
yeah and that's the only other guy in
that category that's that great and is
willing to sit out for somebody believed
in and who needs the money less who
needs it like if Lou Williams is willing
to go I don't need my check this year
fat yeah no but it's not I don't think
it's the money it's his body LeBron is
doing it for he's he's older and you
want to ring oh no 100% I'll never say I
understand that but like he can't admit
that yeah right like he can't go wow I
only got two more good years left he got
to say no we can use this money and help
the communities and he might really
believe that and there's an argument for
that
please poke holes if you see no I'm just
wondering is it possible that the
players don't have as much leverage as
we think like is it possible that
they're contractually obligated like if
they sit out Adam Silver's also said
like anybody who wants to sit out is
finest it means you're not in breach of
contract
sit up he's been the most supportive
like I know that look say what you want
about I'm silver he's a pushover this at
the other you cannot as a player not you
cannot think that this guy doesn't have
your back yeah like he has been so
[ __ ] supportive for this I even
throughout this whole process the fact
that he's like I recognize if we restart
this league we're being selfish here we
need to make a massive contribution to
black lives to show that we can be
selfish but also try to push forward the
agenda that you're doing yeah ah so why
does he need to stop the season because
he got an answer to the he does a good
job of because the commissioner works
for the
that's what people always say about
Goodell you guys misunderstand Goodell
doesn't work for the players he works
for the owners yes silver does a good
job of working for the players and still
keeping the players working for the
owners and Sookie even the players
interest in mind hmm
so he will work for the owners hey let's
do the season we'll make a lot of money
players if you're not in breach of
contract you need to sit out you feel
like you want to sit out go ahead and if
LeBron sat out just LeBron the season
might not happen and that would be
massive patrick beverley said that [ __ ]
he was like if LeBron want to play we
play and I climbed them for that of
course of LeBron want to play we play
that's how this [ __ ] works
yeah if Schultz wants to change the time
of the podcast that's the [ __ ] we're
gonna do if Charlotte wants to change it
on him that's what's [ __ ] you a new
Wonder that's the world that's why I'm
dude that's a good point that if LeBron
says we're gonna sit she could change
and I think it's and don't sit without
getting something out of City yes yes
you know it's like you go listen we are
not playing
unless [ __ ] this bubble [ __ ] in Orlando
[ __ ] the co vid this and the corona that
and got to swab everybody every day [ __ ]
all that
don't sit unless a demand is met what is
a specific demand that you can actually
change make it
[Applause]
you